hey everyone its Johanna here and happy
New Year to kick-start this new year I
want all of you to commit yourself to
stay active for at least 15 minutes a
day six days a week so I've got a full
week total body makeover challenge for
you this is a five-four three-two-one
cardio strength and apps challenge 5
minutes of cardio four minutes of lower
body strength three minutes of apps two
minutes of upper body strength and one
minute of plank this is your challenge
to help you stay active for at least 15
minutes a day so let's start the workout
[Music]
so I'm going to set my timer we'll start
with five minutes of cardio one minute
per exercise and then we'll move on to
strength training okay ready start and
the first exercise is jumping jacks all
right this is also part of your warm up
to live your heart rate up if you are a
beginner and you find this difficult you
can always step side to side so remember
breathe in through your nose and out
through your mouth okay give keep going
make sure you're feeling your legs and
your palms working and to still the
elevate your heart rate to get your
muscles ready for some strength training
workouts get keep doing the second
cardio exercise will be high knees ten
seconds more doing it right let's get
straight into high knees
good bring your knees up as high as you
can
again if you're a beginner just step up
and down all right very nice keep going
tighten those core
[Music]
good one and the third cardio workout is
scan supplier very nice do you feel your
heart rate going up you really pumping
and that's what we want
the higher your heart rate goes the more
calories you burn keep going
fifteen more seconds up let's go come on
let's give our ability a total makeover
this year big skates a plane just help
side to side okay bring your right leg
back and love it back good if you want
to make you more challenging you can
side to touch your angles okay and you
should really feel your butt and your
legs working touch
try to lend your weight on one side nice
keep going
doing good and oral can you work out is
but cake come on let's go haja angles
good good
kick kick your legs back and just touch
your body
McGirt touching a button you can place
your hands if you wanted just as an
indicator good let's go in through your
nose and out through your mouth
try to beef your breathing a pace to
help you with your workout okay keep
going
come on Patrick let's go let's work
those legs
pump your heart rate up and let's burn
calories good ten more seconds and then
we'll just chalk on the spots and move
on to lower body strength training okay
if you just jog on the spot
this is your last minute of cardio and
it's also a quick rest before we move on
to lower body strength training and the
first workout will be squats squats is
one of the best the leg workouts to
really tune up your legs your buns inner
thighs outer thighs and just overall as
well as your core right
I'll go there 30 more seconds and we'll
get straight into squats okay good keep
going
very nice ten more seconds
catch your breath remember to stand
shoot it with the palm face quads look
straight ahead and push up with your
heels ready let's get up for this
workshop we will between 30 seconds each
good
there you go after 30 seconds we want to
challenge ourselves even more and get
into jumping squats okay so this is
really the easier version right five
seconds let's get straight into jumping
squats good 90 seconds keep going jump
we just saw how good keep going keep
pushing let's go only 30 seconds I know
it's hard thing but it's good for your
legs keep going 10 seconds and straight
into hole squats keep going let's go
good
down and pull your squats for 30 seconds
it is burning it will be burning did not
cheat go low and feel your eyes burning
okay and after this we want to move into
lunges start with our right side less
than 10 seconds
hold it I know it's burning hold it hold
it Anna you let's get straight into
lunges right side okay for 30 seconds on
the second wrong
we will move on to lunging on our left
side okay so after this we want to
repeat then tie stuck it up squats and
lunges again keep going
good job well welcome to New York back
to regular squats so let's go done
enough just easy and gentle good keep
going and after this you know what it is
jump squats okay nice and gentle catch
your breath
five seconds let's get your legs ready
and let's jump up and down
10 seconds less come on
keep jumping and after this hole squats
for 30 seconds keep going
get it let's go down and hold it only 30
seconds it's gonna burn that's what we
want that's how we won't be burning fat
and building leap building lean muscles
okay and after this straight on to the
lunges on our left leg whoa breathe in
and out
come on keep holding it keep holding it
it's burning I know it is I can feel it
as well all right good up left leg and
that's it
you are done for your lower body workout
and after this we want to move on to
three minutes of apps keep lunging 30
seconds only keep going down over there
okay for us the first exercise is
bicycle crunches so get down onto the
floor and let's get straight into
bicycle crunches go tweeze opposite side
get opposite side and crunch very nice
really twisted feel your upper abs and
you know what else working only 30
seconds and straight into leg lifts all
right ready
let this up and down okay if you need to
you can support your hands on your butt
or feel a little back good up and down
and straight after this we want to get
into mountain climber
all right only 30 seconds keep going
doing it one more get hop straight into
mountain climber let's go keep your body
straight and bring your knees in very
nice but seconds keep pushing and after
this let's repeat the entire circuit of
apps again keep going keep pushing it
Oh was there last one get back into
bicycle crunches go please
don't bring your legs down and crunch
very good you're pushing it
this is your last second for apps and
then we're going into upper body good
twist it good one letter and let's get
into length this let's go again if your
lower back is arching you can support
your hands on your lower back
[Music]
[Music]
she's going to pushing it one more good
straight into mountain climber let's go
good job after this we want to get into
push-ups okay
keep pushing let's go figure up to a
king good keep your body straight bring
your knees in Oh was there and after
this let's get straight into our body
push-ups good go down and up very good
forgiveness you can go onto your knees
only 30 seconds keep going keep pushing
yourself good I think your backs
do not arch your back very nice
Oh is there and after this we're getting
streets into transcends this good let's
get into triceps dip you can at the
table or chair that's even better
okay the further you bring your legs
away from your body the harder it is so
for an easier version you can bend in
these flat knee okay let's go 30 seconds
good ten more seconds keep pushing and
after this you know what it is we want
to repeat the circuit again so let's get
straight back into crew shops do Vicky
just go onto your knees like what I'm
doing right now okay so if you licks on
the floor slightly and just keep pushing
same thing you want to tighten your abs
and tighten your core right you should
be feeling your chest and your humps
working good it kept feeling stronger
eventually you can go onto your toes
keep pushing keep going over there and
after this you know what it is
back into dips again beginners bringing
these closer and deep up and down as you
get stronger
feel free to extend your knees further
away from your body and always be able
to keep your body close to the chair or
table okay to get a really deep tricep
this and after this moving up one
workout to go which is one minute of
crank right good
scared onto the floor and hold it tight
for a minute
keep going this is your last five four
three two one workouts okay all that
must need to do right now is to
concentrate breathe in and house tighten
your abs tighten your lower back do not
arch your back okay and just focus on
really engaging your core to hold a
plank position breathe in and out if
ever you feel that your arms are tired
you might be overextending it so always
make sure that your elbows and your
shoulders should be in line and just
focus and hold it you're almost there
halfway back keep holding it good jump
you might be feeling that your legs your
arms and your entire body is shaking but
that is absolutely fine because you've
done such an intense workout three more
seconds very good and just let go and
just stretch it out
whoo I'm completely out of breath so
that was a total body makeover challenge
to click start this year if you want to
turn this challenge into a full workout
you can repeat it for two sets and if
you want to challenge yourself even more
repeat it for three sets this will then
be a really effective 30 to 45 minutes
workout to burn calories
to turn up rest for three to five
minutes in between stats so commit
yourself to stay active for at least 15
minutes six days a week this year all
the best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
[Music]
you